The idea is that, uh, a reaction,
if you're talking about two similar
reactions to similar reagents,
the one that's more reactive will be
less selective in which product it gives.
So here we have the
example of two radicals,
a chlorine or bromine atom
reacting with propane.
So when a member of the chain reaction
is that first the at the Halogen Adam
pulls off a hydrogen, generates a radical,
which then takes on a new halogen.
So wherever that first
hydrogen gets pulled off,
that's where the halogen will end up in
the product. But in the case of probate,
and they're two different
hydrogens that can,
you can take off the one in the middle
or the one at the end and it's easier to
take off the one in the middle
because the radical is more stable.
The secondary radical, the internal
one rather than the primary radical.
We talked about that last time,
the extent to which that's true,
but w for whether it's differences in
the starting material or differences in
the product,
however you slice it,
it's easier to take off the hydrogen from
the secondary position in the primary
position.
So the overall heat of the reaction
as you see here is better by a 2.5
kilocalories for generating the secondary
radical as opposed to generating the
primary radical.
And that's true whether chlorine is
doing the abstracting or bromine is doing
the abstracting, right? The same
difference overall in the products,
but the,
the actual change in energy
is much more positive.
In the case of bromine,
it's harder to do than it is in chlorine.
So bromine is more
reactive. Uh, pardon me.
Chlorine is more reactive
and bromine is less reactive.
But notice that the difference
in the activation energies is,
uh,
is more dramatic in the case of bromine
that it is in the case of chlorine,
the earlier the transition comes,
the less difference there's going to be.
So chlorine in the more reactive
reagent is less selective and bromine,
the less reactive agent is more selective,
right?
So this is called the reactivity
selectivity principle.
And it only can apply to the extent
that the transition states are mirroring
what the products do and that
the two reactions are very,
very similar to one another.
And there's not something
else that makes the reaction.
Transition state come much earlier, much
later with a much different structure.
Okay. Now, so in the case of chlorine,
the relative rate of forming secondary
versus primary is a factor of four,
but in the case of bromine, it's almost
10 times as large. The sealer activity,
it's a factor of 35 that
means in the first case,
the difference in energies of the Delta,
Delta g double dagger,
right?
Delta g double dagger is
the activation energy.
But the difference in the activation
energy is 0.8 kilocalories per mole about
one, right? Whereas with
the later transition state,
the difference is very much bigger.
4.5
hi.
So typically more reactive
means less elective.
So if you were a chemist who wanted to
prepare a certain product that required
selectivity,
you might choose to use a less reactive
reagent rather than a more reactive one.
So you'd get a higher yield
of the material you wanted,
even if it was a little more difficult
to do with it and took a little longer.
Okay. Now let's look at this a little
more carefully. The fact that the,
that the difference in
energies of activation in the
case of bromine taking off
a primary or a secondary hydrogen is,
uh,
is the difference in activation is
four and a half kilocalories per mole.
Okay. We just went through why it was
reasonable that it should be large,
but it shouldn't be that large.
Notice that the difference when you get
all the way to products is two and a
half kilocalories per mole.
Right?
Now we had the idea that relative
to a standard say methane,
right?
The energies for that,
for taking off a secondary
hydrogen should be, uh,
either the starting material is less
stable or the product is more stable,
right? Compared to our standard
methane in this case. But at any rate,
there's an increase in stability relative
to the onset to the normal case up at
the top here.
Relative to that,
there's an increase in stability as you
go from starting material to this free
radical intermediate.
Right?
Now there's a question
where the transition state
comes on that if it's early,
you don't see much of, you don't see
much of that increased stability.
If it comes late, you'll see more
of that stability difference.
Okay.
However you see what's nuts here?
What we see is this,
right?
There's more difference at the transition
state than there even is when you get
all the way to product.
Okay?
So how can the transition states be more
different in energy than the products
are? Right? This might not
be a straight line, right?
But at least you'd expect it to be
monotonic not go down and then up again.
There's something we're missing here.
Okay.
Now in the resonance point of view,
one could look,
the trouble we're having is understanding
the energy of transition states.
Regular molecules were more
or less comfortable with,
but transition states are tougher.
Okay,
so one way to look at transition states,
well, like Eular, orbital theory.
Another one is with residents theory
and the problem is that you don't know
which of the ar or Vr,
the hydrogen is bonded to
when it's being transferred.
You could write one resident structure
in which it's bonded to r and bromine is
an Adam. Or You could add, right?
Another residence structure where it's
bonded to br and ar is the free radical,
right?
And it's exactly poised between
those two at the transition state.
That's the definition of the transition
state that you're about halfway there.
Okay.
But what's special about the transition
state is there can be another residence
structure,
a third resonance structure,
which has br minus because bromine
after all is electro negative,
right? And our could be plus. Okay.
So we could have at the
transition state here,
we could have cat I and
character to the Ar.
So that will be helpful
at the transition state.
A third resonance structure here at the
stabilizing things and resonance theory,
right?
But the our cat ion is irrelevant at
when it's our h over here or when it's an
our radical it,
once the radical gets away,
it only has a certain number of electrons,
right? It's not our plus anymore.
So as we'll see next week,
substituted a methyl for hydrogen that
is going from a primary to a secondary
cad ion, right. Stabilizes
the cat eye on a lot.
So this is unusually stable,
but this is important,
this resonance structure
only at the transition state,
not in the starting material
and not in the product.
So we make a mistake in this case if
we assume that the character of the
transition state,
it's intermediate between starting
material and product for this one step
reaction right there actually special
factors that apply only in the transition
state.
And we'll see when we talk about Paris
cyclic reactions that this is very
important.
So sometimes factors involved in
stabilizing transition states could be
different from those involved
in stabilizing either
the starting materials or
the products.
And in these cases we can't
easily rationalize the
activation energy changes on
the basis of the overall exercise
exothermic city or endothermic city of the
reaction step,
right?
Because there's something special
going on at the transition state.
You hope that's not always the case,
that most cases you could do thinking
that more exothermic reactions will be
faster. But you have to be careful
in some cases. Right? And as I said,
we'll see dramatic examples where the
transition state has something special
about it.
When we get to discussing Perry cyclic
reactions in the third quarter of the
course. Okay. Now,
here are two problems for Wednesday
that have to do with free radical
substitution. And you can uh, work in
groups if you went, if you wish. Remember,
we won't have a class on one day and
there won't be discussion section in the
evening on Monday either. Hey, so
here's problem one. Suppose Ma,
as we've just been talking about,
mono chlorination of propane gives end
propyl chloride and ISO propyl chloride
and ratio 43 to 57.
Note,
I say mono chlorination because of
course these products can also have a
hydrogen abstracting and you can
get dechlorination chlorination,
try chlorination, so on. So if you
want to get these ratios accurately,
you do just a little bit of reaction and
see the first products before you get
subsequent substitutions
on the initial products.
You do just a little conversion
and see what the ratio is.
And in the case of propane,
propane,
it's 43 57 primary and
secondary reply hydrogen places.
So if that,
and if Mondo chlorination
of two methyl propane gives,
uh,
that's called ISO butane and also gives
t butyl chloride and one chloro to
methyl propane,
36 and 64% yields.
Notice this is a little,
uh,
test also on knowing what the structures
are of compounds that have these names.
Then predict the products for mono
chlorination of two methyl butane.
Okay, so you're going to
get relative reactivity of
primary and secondary for one
relative reactivity of primary
and tertiary from another.
And then you'll use the
relative reactivity of
secondary and tertiary to solve
the problem. Now you'll find, you'll
find in the textbooks that you have,
every textbook I'm confident has this
kind of problem in it about selectivity in
free. Radical chlorination
probably has the same examples.
So consult your textbook on free radical
halogenation to be sure you're taking
the statistics of hydrogen
numbers properly into account.
Okay, that's the first problem. The
second problem is solved the puzzle.
That's going to be coming up on slide 18.
So hold on and we'll get to that one.
Okay. Now, so we've been talking
about free radical substitution.
Take off a hydrogen and
substituted with a halogen,
but there's another free radical
chain reaction that evolves halogens,
and that's addition to alkenes.
So the starting material or starting
materials are an alkene and hydrogen
haylight,
right?
And somehow you get a radical to
start it off, say a halogen radical,
and instead of pulling off a hydrogen,
it adds to the double bond.
So it gives that intermediate
carbon rat radical.
And then that one is the one that does
an abstraction of hydrogen this time from
Hx,
right?
So you get a product where eight x and
h have added to the carbon carbon double
bond.
So free radical addition to the outfield,
and it's a chain reaction. Once you get
a radical, it can go round and round,
right? Without getting
rid of radicals. Now,
uh, let's, uh, let's look at the
energetics that are involved in this.
A curious thing about this reaction
is that doesn't work with all x H's.
Okay? Now let's see why. Okay,
so we'll analyze the energies
of the bonds we're using here.
Just average bond energies. Okay.
So in the starting material,
we have a carbon carbon double bond
that's worth one 46 and we have,
uh, the x radical and, and,
and also there's x h
the starting material.
And in the product we've added the x h
to the alkene making a new carbon carbon
bond that's worth 83 kilocalories per
mole and a carbon hydrogen bond that's
worth 99.
And we've converted Xh to x radical.
Okay?
So, so if we look at the average, uh,
bond energies involving
fluorine for our x, the product,
we have 116 that's going to go in here.
And in the starting material we're
going to have HX hydrogen fluoride,
135 that's going to go there.
So we're going to add these together,
these bond energies
here. It's 146, uh, for,
for the double bond and 135 for the Xh.
In the case of fluorine
and in the product,
it's going to be 83 and 99 and 100
and 616 for the carbon fluorine bond.
So we add them together and we find out
this is favorable by 17 kilocalories per
mold to do that step. So, uh, pardon me,
to do the overall transformation.
So it's going to be exothermic
in the case of HF, right?
How about in the case of the other
halogen atoms, right? We can use the,
the corresponding values for their
bonds and we get that they're all almost
exactly the same.
So all these additions would
be the same exothermic city.
So you might think they'd all
go at about the same rate,
but they don't at all.
Only HBR works.
Why?
The reason is the overall the trends,
the thermodynamics is fine
for the transformation,
but the question is mechanism
and activation energies, right?
And remember there are two
steps in this reaction. First,
the x adds to the Alkene,
then the new carbon radical
abstracts a hydrogen.
So we have to look at the individual
steps to get what the activation energies
are.
Okay?
So let's first look at that is we
first have to go to this intermediate,
which has a single bond worth,
83 kilocalories per mole instead of
the double bond worth one 46 okay?
So that's going to be fabulously
exothermic this first step,
okay? So that's very exothermic
should be in very fast.
So that's going to be no problem. That's
in the case of of flury, the blue one.
In the case of chlorine, it's still
exothermic. That should be not as fast,
but easy. Still Bromine
still exothermic, right?
But I have done is endothermic.
So that reaction is going to be very slow.
Okay?
So we can understand now
why I had done doesn't work,
but why not fluorine and why not chlorine?
Ah, Derrick, you're right. It's the
second step that's hard for them, right?
Because having this intermediate,
we now have to go here by abstracting
the Xh bond and the Xh bond we have to
break in.
The case of fluorine is fabulously strong,
135 kilocalories per mole.
So that reaction is going to be way
endothermic and it'll be very slow.
So the,
the cyclic mechanism will cough
on the second step for that one.
Right. And in the case of bromine,
it's also in case of chlorine,
the second step is also a little bit
endothermic so it's not very fast,
right? But in the case
of, of uh, of bromine,
it's,
it's exothermic again,
in the case of identity
wouldn't be exothermic,
but the first step is where
the machine coughed. Okay.
So only Broan me in is set up to do
both of these relatively rapidly.
Now you might say, okay, uh,
we'll just, we'll do the others.
We'll just wait longer. Okay. It won't
be as fast because one of the other,
the steps will be slow.
We'll just wait.
But you can't do that with
free radical reactions.
Only HBR works fast enough in both steps
and you need both steps to be fast.
Now we're going to get to that to,
to discussing what would happen otherwise
if both steps aren't fast in just a
minute.
But first I want to comment on one
other aspect of addition to the alkenes.
They're what's called Riggio specificity.
I don't particularly like that word,
but it has to do with when
you add HX to a double bond,
there are two regions they could go to.
The h could go here and the
x here or vice versa. Okay.
So when we add HX,
we could imagine x going to this
carbon or h going to this carbon.
Right.
And it turns out that for any
halogen that can undergo edition,
right?
There's a principle called Markov
knockoff orientation after a Russian,
a chemist, the latter part
of the, of the 19th century.
And he discovered this in 1870 just
about the time that people knew about
structures of course,
that what you tended to get was the
more substituted haylight that is the ex
went to the carbon between these two
that has more substituents on it.
Right.
And it's understood in terms of initial
addition of h plus this was figured out
in the 1930s.
Right.
And it's because of this ionic
mechanism that we'll discuss in a,
in three weeks that, that uh, the
mark cognit cough orientation works.
We'll talk about that when we come to it.
But what's important is when you do
this HBR edition by the free radical
mechanism,
the cyclic mechanism,
you get the anti Markovnikov product.
It goes exactly the other way.
The bromine goes on the
less substituted carbon.
So this was quite a mystery for people
in the early part or from 1870 on why bro
me and with some time HBR
was sometimes a bad actor.
Sometimes it would give the Markovnikov
product the expected when that all the
other ha ha hydrogen haylight we give,
but sometimes it gave the other and it
didn't. It tended not to give mixtures.
It would give all one or all of the other.
But in the 1930s 1933 it was found out
that this happened when the samples
contained little bits of peroxide.
Now let's see why that is.
It's because it's an initiator
of radical change. Remember,
you needed some way to have a
radical to begin this whole process.
So if you have r o r of peroxide
and Hbr and the owl keyed,
the first thing that happens in this
mechanism is that you break the o bond to
get to Aro radicals.
Now you have the radical that
can do a hydrogen abstraction.
So it abstracts hydrogen from Hbr
and now you're into the machine.
You have X. Dot. That can
add to the Alkene, right?
And get one or the other
of those two radicals.
Now if you've got the radical on the left,
you'd get Markovnikov orientation,
cause h would come here the next time,
but abstracts h from HBR.
But in fact this is the one you get
because the secondary radical is more
stable. Okay? So when
you're getting radicals,
you get that one rather than
the primary radical, right?
So now,
so that's,
that explains that the regio specificity
of the special addition of Hbr,
but only if you can get free radicals.
Now,
why can't you just do
it, uh, waiting longer?
This has to do with the rate law
when you have a catalytic cycle,
right?
So there to discuss it in this case.
But it's important in all sorts
of cases where there's Catalin,
[inaudible] and Inorganic
Chemistry and biochemistry.
When they're catalin this
and you have these cycles,
the rate laws you get are a little bit
different from what you might expect.
Okay? So where there are
two steps in this reaction.
The first step has a certain rate
constant and of course the rate then
multiplies that rate constant
by concentrations to get a rate.
And the two reagents are
our h and X. Dot. Okay.
Then there's the second step,
which has some other rate constant k two
and it's starting with Delia's starting
materials are in this case, the
dye halogen and R. Dot. Okay.
Now, a couple of years
ago when we were having a,
like a visiting lecture by
a Berry Sharpless who uh,
who won the Nobel prize in
Catalin assists, he made it,
you can look at his
lecture if you want to,
but one thing he said caught
my imagination. He said,
this is a real democracy.
Catalin Isis.
What did he mean by it being a democracy?
It's because when this thing
is going around, right,
these two rates have to be equal.
Whatever k one times those is
has to equal k two times those.
And the,
the concentration of the free radicals,
we'll adjust the ratio of the
two to make those two equal.
What would happen if the first one we're
really fast and the second one were
slow, then you would
convert x.to R. Dot. Okay.
So you'd have a big R. Dot. Which would
favor the second one and a small x.
Dot on the first one, and
soon, soon they'd become equal.
And then the thing could go around
at whatever rate that they allow.
But both steps are involved.
These two things become equal.
So that's what he meant by a
democracy that they were equal.
Now you can see an example of that.
If you look down on the,
on the Garden State Parkway here,
uh,
notice that for the,
for the cars going north,
uh, there's a lot of difference between
these lanes of traffic and these lanes of
traffic. And the same is
true here. There's a big
difference between those two.
Okay?
And the reason is that this is
Kay ash and this is easy pass.
Okay?
So if we look just at the cash lanes,
you notice that there's
a low rate constant here.
You've got lots of starting material
building up its concentration,
trying to get through paying,
okay. But once they get through,
they can accelerate and go on fine,
right?
So here you have a right
high rate constant. Here you
have a low rate constant,
but the number of cars per minute,
the fluxes here and here are the same,
right?
The cars that come here also end up here.
So the is that here you have
high concentration. Here
you have low concentration,
but the rates are the same.
The small rate constant paying cash times
the high concentration is the same as
the big rate constant. Once you've
speeded up times the low concentration.
So it's the same as you go
around in the cycle, right?
The rates of the two have to be the same,
even though the rate constants are
different. So the concentrations adjust,
right? And you'll notice as
Sharpless said in that lecture,
if there's a slow step like this one,
then there's 99.9% of the titanium
is what he was calling you about.
Remember we talked about that last time?
That's what he was talking about.
They're stuffed before this big mountain
that goes way up like Mount Everest.
He said he's a colorful speaker.
If you get that barrier down,
then the rate goes way up. And if
you get them all at the same height,
then you're really rolling.
So notice that's what happens.
The easy pass lane, right?
That the uh, that the uh,
that they go at the same rate because
you've gotten that first big rate,
determine that rate constant down,
up the barrier down for that first step.
Okay? Now let's, let's, uh, apply that
principle back to this catalytic cycle.
So we had from the previous slide that
these two had to be equal when the,
when the machine is running.
Okay?
Now suppose k one is
small and k two is large.
Okay?
So now,
how does the rate the amount of material
you produce per minute depend on the
concentration of r h?
Yeah,
well, we can look here. If
we, let's suppose what this,
we could rearrange this to say
that the ratio of X. Dot. R.
Dot is k two times x two over k one
times rh that we get by just dividing
through, right? So we know
the ratio of these two,
but the total of the two, right? But
there's a certain amount of radical there.
It could be as you go around the cycle,
it could be either in the form of x.
Dot or in the form of R. Dot.
So the ratio can change, right?
But the total amount is limited.
Okay,
so let us suppose that x.is dominant,
right?
Suppose there's 98 to two
the ratio of X. Dot. R. Dot.
Okay.
And now let's double the amount of our H,
right?
We're leaving the radicals the same, but
we're doubling the amount of RH, right?
So we're going to double
this. Double this, right?
Leave that the same. These are fixed
constants, but we're doubling this.
So what's going to happen?
The ratio is going to change.
That's what we've just been talking
about, right? So instead of 98 to two,
we have to get a ratio
that's only half that big,
right? We have a hundred radicals to deal
with. They're in the form of 98 X. Dot.
And to R. Dot. And we want to, we have to,
if we double rh up here, right? We're
interested in what that exponent is.
We double our age.
We're going to have that ratio.
How will we do it?
We still have a hundred radicals,
right? But instead of 98 to two, it's,
if we assume that the sum is constant,
we are going to have 96 to four.
Everybody see that? That's twice.
That's that's this is half.
This ratio is half that ratio.
Very close.
Okay.
But no, how much did that change?
The concentration of X. Dot.
It notice that doubled the
concentration of R. Dot.
But it hardly changed the concentration
of X. Dot. At all in relative terms, what?
Just went to 96 from [inaudible] 98 right?
So x.is still the same concentration,
right?
So the rate of the rate at
which you go through here,
which is the same as the rate you go
through here, is now the same here.
This one has been doubled and
this one is practically the same.
It's 96 instead of 98.
So what happened to the rate approximately
that the rate doubled?
So who's surprised that when you
double the starting material here,
you double the rate that is that
the question mark there is about to,
I see no hands, right?
What do you expect? Okay,
so that grows,
this rate grows by that Mt.
1.96 fold practically too,
right?
So it's,
it's first order in rh.
Did I say too before it's first
order in our age, no one's surprise.
Okay, so the rate, and of course the
rate is also proportional to k one.
Okay.
Now how about if we change the
concentration of x to what's its exponent?
So let's do the same analysis. Now we're
going to double, we're going to double,
uh,
x two.
So we'll double x two and now
we're going to have to, uh,
we're going to have to double,
uh, the ratio of X. Dot. R. Dot.
Right?
Remember we're starting from 98 to two.
What do we do in order
to double that ratio?
We have to go 99 to one.
Everybody see that?
Okay,
now going nine,
that's now going to make a difference
because if we look at this rate,
which is the same as that rate,
it's the same k to the same,
uh, uh, the same, uh, department,
we doubled x too. But R. Dot.
Is now only half as big as it was before.
Okay?
So, uh, we, we doubled x
too, but we have R. Dot.
So we did an accelerated the doll,
right?
So it's zero order and next to,
so it depends on the concentration
to this starting material,
the one that goes into the slow step.
But it doesn't depend on the
concentration of this starting material.
The one that goes into the fast step.
Yeah,
that's, so that's a, that's probably if
I had asked you, my guess is if I, the,
I should've, we should've done this
as a democracy is Sharpless said,
and I should have asked you before,
what do you think that exponent is and
what do you think act that exponent, this,
my guess is you'd have said they're
both one, but in fact that one. Zero.
Yeah.
Okay. The rate is also there. For
instance, if it's insensitive to x two,
it's also insensitive to k
two. Okay. So in summary,
when one step of a cycle is
much slower than the others,
the rate of cycling is pretty insensitive
to the rate constant and concentration
of the incoming region for the fast step.
All right.
Because concentration of the minor
form of recycling reagent adjust to
compensate and fractional changes in
concentration of the dominant radical are
much more modest. Okay.
Uh, so the rates, uh,
obviously going to be proportional
to the amount of radical no,
there's no surprise that if
you're running 13 machines,
it's going to be 13 times faster
than running just one machine.
But that's the other factor that we were
going to get to a few minutes ago that
we're going to have initiation
and termination and in by
fancying up the slides.
I forgot to animate that
properly, sorry. Okay,
so initiation typically involves breaking
a weak bond with light heat or adding
an electron or sometimes taking
away an electron. So heat,
you can take a week bond and with
heat break it to get to radicals.
The oxygen oxygen bond is unusually weak
as we are going to be discussing not
long from now. Right?
Or you can use light.
We talked about this last semester
already. Take an electron that's in sigma,
put it in Sigma Star and the
chlorides will come apart.
All right,
this one has an energy, a 30
kilocalories per mole. What? What?
What are the energies of
other sigma bonds? We've been
talking about more or less
C, C or c h for example, order magnitude.
100 right? Three times a strong.
So this is an unusually weak bond.
So you can do it with heat.
And the reason it's weak is because
you have repulsion among these unshared
pairs of electrons that you
don't have in the other cases.
We'll talk about that in just
a minute as well. All right?
Or you can put an electron
into Sigma Star, right?
By a reduction reaction and get Ooh,
minus.
But the free radical,
Ooh,
which could do a hydrogen abstraction
and start the chain, right?
But even if you're generating radicals,
right,
you can lose by radicals being destroyed.
Because if both, remember we said,
why not just wait longer and let this
machine go around even if it's going
slower?
The reason is that's not all the radicals
can do abstracting hydrogens or add
into double bonds if
radicals find each other.
The Somo Somo reaction is really easy,
right?
It's all downhill and
energy. All right? Uh,
so you have to be sure
they don't find partners.
And that process is called termination
of a free radical chain reaction.
So you have initiation that generates
the radicals that allow the machine to
work propagation.
That's the cycling of the machine and
termination, which destroys the machines,
right? You remember the, uh, New Hampshire
license plate? It says live free or die.
If the radicals aren't free from
one another, Bingo, they're gone.
So that's termination.
Okay,
so now how about the kinetic
order in the amount of initiator?
You might think if you initiate,
uh, the chains twice as fast.
If you make, if you have twice
as many machines operating,
then the rate,
the reaction should be twice as fast.
That overall rate should be twice as fast,
but that won't,
that isn't true as you'll see here.
So the initiation indeed depends
on how much initiator you have.
And it has a certain rate constant
for initiation to give those radicals.
And the rate of four radicals
is therefore first order.
It's proportional to the
concentration of the precursor,
a termination as two radicals
coming together. Uh, it,
it could be any radicals.
It could be the x dots coming together.
It could be our dots coming
together, or it could be an r. Dot.
Coming together with an X. Dot. All
of those reactions are a radical plus.
A radical will terminate.
And the rate of destroying
radicals is of course second order.
And how many radicals there are,
right?
Because two of them have to come
together and it's steady state.
Once the thing is cranking along
the rate of initiation and the,
which is this right here,
and the rate of termination must be
the same cause we're in a steady state.
We're not changing the number of machines.
Okay?
So once we get to steady state,
then those two will be a
proportional to one another.
Or the amount of R.
Dot is proportional to the peroxide
to the one half power because of that
termination, right? So in fact,
if the rate of the reaction
is proportional to how
many machines you have to,
the R.
Dot.
Is proportional to the square root
of the amount of initiator there,
because the destruction is second order.
So that's an interesting additional rate
law that when you see that half order
in this case, it means that
there's a chain reaction going on,
right?
And termination is involved.
So the answer is one half order.
And now we're going to,
we're going to shift from free radical
reactions toward ionic reactions by
considering free radical
reactions that involve ions.
And the reason this is important to
make this transition is because ionic
reactions are so different because
they're dependent on solvent in ways that
radical reactions aren't.
So here's another substitution reaction
where now instead of a halogen,
instead of having CLC l here,
we have a nitrogen chlorine bond.
Okay?
So we have nitrogen radicals that can
pull off hydrogen to generate an a mean
the Nh bond of an amine and give a
free radical just as we did before,
which then can pull chlorine
off here to make RCL.
So we can do free radical halogenation,
but instead of using a halogen,
we use a Clore of mead.
Right now,
this bond is about a hundred kilocalories
per mole. This one is a weak bond,
about 46 calories, calories
per bowl. Again, like chlorine,
chlorine would be a weak bond,
and those product ones are strong bonds.
So the first step is a
little bit exothermic.
And the last step is, is, uh, pardon me.
The first step goes from a strong
bond to a weak bond. It's Endothermic,
right?
So that slow the second one,
it goes from a weak bond to a strong bond
that's exothermic. So that one's fast.
So this,
the top one is the slow step,
but that means that this will be the
dominant species between these two.
You'll have a lot of this so that
this rate can be equal to this rate,
not much R. Dot. At any given time. Okay?
And this is then what happens?
We have the free radical, uh,
which approach, which, uh, uh, pardon me,
two free radicals can
come together in this way.
That one radical takes the hydrogen
from this ice appropriate group,
the hydrogen here from the other one.
So that's the termination of
the rate of reaction, right?
That's what's going to kill it,
right?
So that's slowing the reaction
down by destroying machines.
So if we could retard this process,
then we can speed up the reaction.
If you don't have termination anymore.
Now,
so this is termination by
hydrogen atom transfers.
Get rid of the radicals
and stop the machine.
Now what happens if you add acid?
Yeah.
Now you protonate the unshared
pair here in the mean,
right,
and charge.
We'll keep the member the most
of the radicals are in this form,
right?
Okay.
But the charge, if they're both
charged, it'll keep them apart.
And if they're a apart,
then they don't terminate.
So you can slow down the termination
by protonating these free radicals.
Yeah.
Now let's look at these results
from 1971 on using this reagent.
This is one step in the reaction that
chloro mean to to a substitute to halogen
eight a long chain alcohol.
Okay?
So what are graphed here is what percent
of isomers you get for substitute for
putting chlorine on this carbon or this
carbon or this carbon or this carbon or
this cover of this carbon.
This carbon.
Okay.
And you can see that you don't get more
than 20% of any of them and you get a
real dog's breakfast mixture
here of the vise verse.
This is useless, right? You'd have to do,
you get a very low yield and
whatever it was you wanted.
And you have to do a lot
of work to purify it.
If you do it in 50% sulfuric acid,
right?
It's pretty much the same story.
If you do it in 60% sulfuric acid,
it's a little bit better.
You get more of this,
okay?
But if you do it in 70% sulfuric acid,
you get almost all of
this material chlorination
specifically at that position.
So isn't that a great mechanism? Right?
By choice, by changing the solvent,
by making it a strong acid,
you can make it selective for this one.
See the advantage of that
obvious in synthesis.
Why?
Why wouldn't you change from notice?
50 and 60% didn't make much difference,
a little difference,
but going to 70% really
zoomed up on that one.
So why does change in
the acid concentration
influenced the seal activity?
I notice those are mead radicals
are not really strong basis.
It takes a very strong acid
to get most of this stuff.
Protonated right? To
add another, uh, to add,
to add this proton on there
takes a really strong acid.
When you get to 70% it's
almost, well, pardon me,
I said exactly the wrong
thing and I apologize.
I forget what I just said for
the last 20 seconds. Okay.
The amine is a reasonable base.
It's easily protonated.
Even in weak acid,
this is protonated,
but there's another base in the
system that's hard to protonate.
And what's that
Sebastian?
The alcohol could be protonated,
but you need a really strong acid
to protonate the alcohol. Okay?
So if you hear the r o h has
half protonated right now,
if it's,
if this molecule is protonated,
it's hard to get the two protonated things
together. So the reaction slows down,
the reaction,
the reaction still proceeds,
but it goes with the material
that's not protonated. Okay.
And it's only half protonated,
but at 70% it's fully protonated.
Everything is like that.
Now the reaction will slow down, right?
So it won't be as fast. But what,
what's the advantage?
It's hard for the charges to get together,
so they'll stay apart
to the extent they can.
So what
I,
Aisha,
what react here near the other positive
charge. It'll react out at the end.
It'll get a secondary cut.
Hydrogen, not the primary.
Why don't we've talked about that
already, right? But it gets this one,
not even this one,
right?
Isn't that a cute idea to use the
charges to make the things selective,
but it only happens if you can
make both reagents be charged.
This one's easy to charge,
but this one only when you get
in very strong sulfuric acid.
So I've always admired that experiment.
Yeah.
Okay. So it comes down there in
order to do, it's a reaction.
Now what I haven't
shown is reacting there.
Yeah,
and this is going to be
related to your next problem.
So if you use 30% sulfuric acid,
then you get a completely
different product.
Remember I went 50 60 70 but if you,
if you,
if you use 30% sulfuric acid,
then you get that product.
Yeah.
This carbon becomes an ester
or an acid.
So this carbon gets oxidized.
The two H's are removed and oxygen's put
on and that probably got formed from an
Aldehyde. The first thing that
probably happened was that you,
that you changed this ch,
two o h two c double bond o h.
Okay.
And mostly that's formed not by erratic.
It could be four by the
radical chain reaction, right?
But probably it's not.
It's probably formed by a
Homo Lubo reaction call.
An oxidation reaction
involving this reagent,
right?
Remember the original reagent we're using,
the thing you put in is chloramines
and cl and an as 30% acid.
It's protonated.
So it's probably a reaction
between this stuff at this, right?
It could be the free radical reaction,
but it's probably a Hobo Lumo reaction
that's able to convert this to that.
And this is that puzzle that your
other problem for a week from today,
since we're not having a class on
Monday or a week from the apartment next
Wednesday,
uh,
the puzzle is to propose mechanisms to
form the Aldehyde involving both sub two
steps,
a substitution,
but also an elimination reaction
reaction with a base pay.
So now that substitution reaction could
either be the radical substitution,
this mechanism going like that,
or it could be a homo Lumo reaction.
Right?
So you, I've said you could get
together and work on this in groups.
So I think you should be
able to do both of these,
both the free radical
substitution and the Hobo Lobo,
that together with elimination,
right,
removing HX gives rise to the Aldehyde.
So see if you can figure out why at 30%
so very cast that you get a completely
different product.
Uh,
I think that's enough for now. Yeah.
We'll go onto this problem next time.